Galileo had discovered he didn't invent
the telescope but he was the first
observational astronomer to look through
a telescope conceive a scientific
hypothesis subjected to tests and refine
his model and that's why you shouldn't
trust the scientists because any one of
those stages he had great blunders I
mean he was really brilliant I always
say you know he could have had a great
career if he didn't make these blunders
Einstein had great blunders there's not
a serious scientist who hasn't made a
serious mistake and with Galileo
fortunately or unfortunately those
mistakes usually evolved around the
politics of the day not the science
oh